[Music]
there's a conflict bubbling beneath the
surface as germans head for the most
important elections in decades
september's results will determine who
will replace angela merkel as german
chancellor
while it's true that the majority of
voters will decide on who leads germany
into the post-mark or future there's a
generational clash politicians simply
don't want to talk about
like never before it's germany's older
generations the 50 plus who are calling
the political shots
and while there is much talk of the
future
those who will live through most of it
germany's young will have the least to
say about it
and
i could have never imagined that kind of
aggression and anger and
frustration that was being directed at
us the younger generations who are just
talking what the science has been
telling for the past 40 years for those
generations in the driving seat this
clash of interests often doesn't feel
that way when i'm created
quite a gap in perception between old
and young and right in the middle of
that gap is where the political arena is
set for the current election campaign
as politicians try to position
themselves to succeed angela mackel they
all talk of the future but at the same
time they all have to at least appear to
be on the side of older voters
it's about the demographics
soaring german birth rates created a
peak in the 1960s the age of the baby
boomer generation after that birth rates
plummeted that makes this vote all about
the age distribution
that peak and the cliff that came
afterwards created very differently
sized generations
the young groups are outnumbered by the
old at a ratio of at least two to one
when germans go to the polls on
september the 26th
voters over 50 will make up almost 60
percent of the electorate while the
under 30s will make up just
14.4 percent
all of this wouldn't matter if aid had
no effect on how people vote
but it does
the last eu elections showed older and
younger voters pulling in different
directions there was a remarkable
difference in generational support for
the green party and angela mackel's
conservative blog and current polls
suggest that this division will continue
into this september's general elections
among the under 30s 36 percent are
expected to vote for the green party
just 16
are expected to vote for mackel's
conservatives
among the over 60s it's almost a
complete reversal with 36 expected to
vote for the conservatives and just 14
percent expected to vote green
and their preferences will matter more
because they have millions more in terms
of voting power
with half of the population heading
towards retirement already there it's
the great germans who hold the keys to
the future
in the democratic
but we need protests on the streets
because
someone needs to interrupt this whole
business as usual
someone needs to step out of that
comfort zone and say this is not the way
we can keep going
and even all the stories about you know
small improvements and small
developments that cannot overshadow
how bad
people and society have messed up
and so
we need to to ring this alarm bell and i
guess that works
that doesn't work that well usually
when you're still
you know
muddled up within the systems
that maintain the business as usual but
friday's for future can't change those
numbers young voters will remain a
minority for decades to come and to make
policy changes you need a majority
that's democracy and that's also how
angela mackel explained
is
what would you say
well i guess politics isn't about
finding majorities but about fighting
for majorities
a majority doesn't just you know pop up
somewhere for some
climate justice measure but it's
something you have to fight for and i
guess
we need our leaders to be able and to be
willing to fight for those majorities
that's democracy but that's also the
christ win neither the chancellor nor
young voters can escape that
generational divide at the ballot box
and it's creating disillusionment among
the young scriptures
and
so while the german political system is
stuck in a gear comfortable for the baby
boomer plus generations time is ticking
away for tackling the challenges that
will mostly affect the young
the fridays for future movement help
prepare the ground for climate change
becoming the hot button issue of this
election campaign
this summer's devastating flash floods
left some 200 people dead and a 50
billion euro bill to rebuild what had
been destroyed the link to global
warming and the fear of more disasters
to come push climate change to the top
of the political agenda
yet it's still not clear whether voters
will respond by choosing parties and
policies that would mean tangible
changes to their lifestyle but we need
older generations to acknowledge that
there is this price tag to all the
development and the welfare and that
everything that's been worked for
and
we need
people to kind of
wake up to that
and
you know when we started try this for
future i thought we just had to remind
other generations of what is happening
around the world
and i thought we would just kind of go
up and say sorry guys don't want to
interrupt very quickly there's a climate
crisis and someone needs to start acting
like we're in a crisis
and what happened was the most insane
and most absurd um
fight back against us like the climate
crisis was our fault just because we
were talking about it
a scientist herself angela merkel was
one of the first world leaders to raise
the alarm on climate change even
traveling to greenland in a stunt to
call for action back in 2007.
she was dubbed the climate chancellor
early in her tenure the crisis is not
new territory for her yet this year she
had to admit she'd failed to meet her
own ambitions
um
but the policies in place to do that
speeding up were not good enough that's
according to the constitutional court
which issued a landmark ruling that made
waves around the world the plaintiffs
some of whom are still very young are
seeing their liberties violated by
irreversibly shifting the burden of
saving emissions past the year 2030.
germany's climate policy was so unfair
it was unconstitutional and that forced
politicians to acknowledge two things
first of all that there is this
generational conflict not just beneath
the surface
and that future policy making without
taking young people into account could
see them before the cause
jolted into action mackel's government
shifted its co2 neutrality goal forward
by five years bringing it almost in line
with the greens
a giant leap for mackel's government but
a very small step compared to the
demands coming from the streets but in
the science at la at least i mean in the
last 30 years it was clear that we would
have needed such a change and such a
transformation um in all these sectors
and now it is like nearly too late and
that's why these elections in september
are so relevant and so important
those elections have climate high on the
agenda pushed there by fires across
europe and floods in germany
this summer's report from the
intergovernmental panel on climate
change also underlined that urgency
its more than 200 scientists predict the
earth will pass the 1.5 degree of
warming mark by the 2030s
much earlier than previously predicted
and that even if we take drastic action
now
and yet smooth monsieur industrial
freelancers
young people will be the ones who have
to build a future in the climate changed
world
so in order to
stay below 1.5 the
future coalition would have to agree on
a program that is more radical than any
of the manifestos that we've written
before that's kind of unlikely so this
election
will impossibly lead us to be on a safe
pathway to 1.5 degrees or prepare this
plan
it can
maybe provide this foundation that we
need to then fight for 1.5 but it will
need a lot of work and that will be
tough fights we'll have to fight
what most parties have left open though
is whether they will have the political
stomach to confront those 50-plus
generations with the sacrifices that
will be needed to meet those new climate
targets
the other crisis that is exposing
germany's generation gap is corona the
entire country spent months in
significant lockdown it was an approach
firmly based on scientific advice
initially angela mackel was hailed for
her decisive action
visa
to this day germany has one of the
lowest covert death rates in the world
but opinions on her leadership are split
depending on which age group you talk to
via skelophilist is immortal
and this is
before vaccines became widely available
successive lockdowns were germany's main
answer to fight the pandemic
and those closed schools and playgrounds
the cancelled apprenticeships and
postponed training courses had a
devastating effect on the young
the lockdown was to protect the old but
germany's digital infrastructure failed
to offer alternatives to the young
they felt like the big losers of the
crisis
would be that there is a huge
generational injustice that is being
maintained and
um
you know not
being looked at enough
there were
sweet moments of solidarity of course
when younger people stayed inside to
protect the older ones when older people
stood up and said younger ones need to
have the right to go to school or to go
to clubs or to have some kind of leisure
activity moments
but all in all what
we saw how especially younger
generations were just
you know drastically and
ignored a lot of the times so what
happened why would angela merkel the
leader known for handling any crisis
thrown at her simply forget about the
younger generation
sebastian kurtz
as the german economy was hit by the
lockdowns the government borrowed
billions to keep the country afloat
now a
650 billion euro debt bill is
infuriating those who feel their needs
were neglected when schools and
universities were shut we need
generational justice and
the actual policies are not made for
for young people they are made for old
people and while football stadiums and
concert halls are reopening
many schools still don't have a clear
plan on how to continue classes in the
face of a fourth covet wave
the elections on the 26th of september
will also decide on which group of
society continues to have priority on
getting their life back and for the
moment it doesn't look like the young
have moved up that list thirdly i
wouldn't be talking about generational
justice without mentioning the p word
pensions epitomize the very stability
germany stands for only germany's
pension system is just four years away
from hitting a brick wall
everyone knows it but politicians don't
want to talk about it because it would
mean explaining to those majority baby
boomer plus generations that they may be
about to have a financial haircut
pensions are the most obvious clash of
interests between the generations
over the next couple of years that
post-war baby boomer generation will
start going into retirement pretty much
all at
foreign
so while baby boomers are still
expecting more the pension system as it
stands won't be able to fulfill those
promises made in the past the sheer
numbers don't match and whatever
adjustment is made to soften the blow a
big hit is coming as a system that still
relies on more people paying in than
getting anything out tips over into more
people receiving a pension than paying
in
the latest government report warns of a
shock-like effect only four years away a
german angst issue for politicians which
has left lawmakers paralyzed they're
afraid of of the young generation
because
some of them believe they will never get
a pension because by then the pension
system will be broke they're afraid of
the old person because they actually
vote in masses and they don't want to
have a
reduction in their
purchasing power
of pensions they they are used to get a
pension increase by three four percent
over the last 10 years uh and now
suddenly it should be only
one percent or zero
i have very mixed feelings about the
pension debate um i see how my mom for
instance who's been working for 40 years
isn't really
expecting to get any pensions she can
live off and she's a nurse and she's
been working so hard and it's
um
a weird situation
and at the same time
you know when we talk about pensions of
my generation
i don't think the um aspect of tax
system will be our biggest problem in
2018 and we'll be somewhere else
germany's politicians aren't expected to
solve the country's pension dilemma
anytime soon but whatever they do they
will need a majority from those about to
retire
i would love to see a baby boomer
generation who says okay we are in
different crisis and multiple crises um
at the moment and we are kind of
responsible for them not on every
individual level but on a systemic level
and
we are taking the responsibility and as
a whole society together with young
generations with older generations we
are trying to make it and we are trying
to solve
the social crisis and the climate crisis
and bio biodiversity and so on
democracies rely on majorities willing
to bridge those gaps between
generational interests and attitudes
with the power of the majority firmly in
the hands of those baby boomer plus
generations younger germans are set to
continue their campaign on the streets
way beyond those landmark elections in
september
outnumbered at the ballot box they know
that they will need those baby boomers
to stand with them well it's an odd
odd situation of course for younger
generations knowing that so many people
will vote and decide about our future
without having to live through that very
future
and so
yeah we are not just talking about
climate justice but we're talking about
generational justice
and we need to see that
also within politics and political
programs
the ability to take younger perspectives
into account even if they can't vote
themselves yet essentially those under
30 today are at the mercy of the older
generations how and whether the
post-medical government will address
this will also give an indication on
where europe the world's oldest
continent is heading where they will
focus on re-establishing the status quo
or whether it will act in the interest
of the future generations these
elections will show how much room there
is for compromise